.
ADAM IS A GRE GUY.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY,"
STRAIGHT-AHEADSPECIAL
VESTIGATION INTO
NANCY PELOSI'S HUSBAND THE GUY
THAT GOT T DUI.
BUT THIS TE THE PSIBILITY OF
INSIDER TRADI.
WE WILTELL YOU ALL AUT IT AT
ALSO ANGER TOWARD AN ARMED HERO
WHO SHOT A GUN MEN ANDIKELY
VE DOZENS OF LIVES.
LATER WE WILL REVE HOW BORDER
STES MAY HAVE FINALLY
DISCOVERED THE PERFECT SOLUTION
TO JOE BIDEN'S OPEN BORDE
POLICIES.IT MIGHT BE THE PERFECT
SOLUTION.
FOR US TONIGHT WE ARE ATHE END
OF A TYPICALONDAY FOR OUR
AILINGOMMANDER-IN-CHIEF WHILEMOT
WORK, THE PRESINT OF THE
UNITED STATES TOOK THE DAY OFF
YETGAIN.
HE TOOK WHOLE TRIP AND
EVERYTHING WITH ZERO PUBLIC
EVEN.
HE NEE ALL THE REST AER WHAT
WAS A DISASTROUS TRIP ABROAD.
PER USUAL, WELL, HE FAID TO
DELIVE
HE NEVER GOT A COMMITMENT FROM
SAUDI ARABIA.
HE'S BEEN GGING OPEC, THE
SAUDIS TO PRODUCEORE OIL WHICH
IS DB IN AND OF ITSEL BECAUSE
WE HAVE MORE ENERGY HERE.
THAT CANROVIDE FOR OUR NEEDSAND.
DIDN'T HOLD THE KGDOM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR T MURDER OF
THE U.S. SPACE REPORTE
THERE WERE QUESTIONSHETHER THE
SUBJECTS WERE DISCUSSED.
A GUY HE REFERRED TO AS A
MURDER, PARIAH, THE GUY WHO
GOTWAY WITH MURDER.
WHEN T PRESIDENT RETURNED HOME
TO THE WHI HOUSE, HE WASN'T
INTEREED IN ANSRING YOUR
ESTIONS ABOUT HIS EARRASSING
TRIPBROAD.
IT WAS EMBARRASSING.
TAKEOOK.
>> WHY DON'T YOU GUYS TALK ABOU?
>> Sn: HEY, JACK, YOU GUY
ARE ALL AKE AND EVERYING.
ULTIMATELY, THIS I A TRIP THAT
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T NEED TO MAKE.
WE HAVEORE THAN ENOUG OIL,
GAS, COALIGHT IN THE GROUND AT
HOME.
WE CAN DIG DOMESTILLY AND NOT
RELY ON COURIES THAT HATE OUR
GUTS.
ACCOING TO THEELIGIOUS
CLIMATE ALARMIST CALLED,
PORTING OIL FROM SAUDI ARABIA,
SHIPPING AND ACROSS THE WORLD IN
OUR COUNTRYOMESTICALLY.
IT DON'T WE DESERVE AN
EXPLANATION ON THIS?
THIS INSANE THINKING?
LIESN
WHY IS IT OKAYO EXTRACT ABROAD
BUTAN'T DO IT DOMESTICALLY
WHEN WE DO IT DOMESTILLY WE DO
IT FASTER,HEAPER, AND CLEANER?
WHY WOULDN'T WE DO ITERE?
JOE GOES BEGGING AND PLEING TO
PARI NATIONS AND COMES HOME
EMPTY-HANDED.
THE PRICE BY THE WAY OF A BARREL
OF OIL WENT HIGHER CAUSE JOE
ILED.
W DEMOCRATS AND BIDEN'S
PROTECTORSN THE MEDIA MOB,
EVEN THEY CAN'T RELY EXCUSEALL .
TAKE A LOOK.
>> H FIST BUMPED THE MAN
RESPONSIBLE ACCORDING THEM
RECTOR OF NATIONALINTELLIGENCE,L
MURDER OF "WASHINGTON POST"
JOURNALISTND DISMEMBERING HIM
WITHONE SAW.
THE FIST BUMP PHOTOGRAPHED A LOT
OF AMERICANSAW THAT, AND WERE
VOLTED BY IT.
>> SHOULD DEN HAVE GONE.
>> I DON'T THI SO.
YOU DON'T HAVE LEADER OF T
UNTRY WHO ISNVOLVED IN THE
MURDER OA "WASHINGTON POST"
JONALIST.I DON'T THINK THAT TYP.
>> I DON THINK BIDEN GET
ATTACKEDECAUSE HE'S A
PRESENT OR A DEMOCTIC
PRESENT.
I THINK IT'S BAD NO MATTE HOW
YOU OK AT IT.
>> Sean: FIS PUMPING THE
MURDER OF.
ONE THING I NOTICED IN THE TAPE
IS YOU SEE BERNIE SANDERS.
I THINK HE'S OLDER THAN JOE.
HE'S GOT HIS ACT TOGETHER,
COGNITELY ALERT, HE'S GOT A
LOOF ENERGY.
I DON'T TNK HE CHANGED MUCH IN
THE LAST 20 YEARS.
STILL GOT THEASTBALL.
JODOESN'T.
EVERYTHING THAT'S GONE WRG FOR
BIDEN, A WHOPPING 75% OF
AMERICAN HSEHOLDS NOWAYING
THAT THEIR INCOMIS FALLING
BEHIND THE COST-OF-LIVING,
TWO-IRDS OF AMERICANS AND
GOING HIGHER LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
AS I PREDICTED ON E PROGRAM,
WHAT DID I SAY?
WATCH THE HSING MARKET BECAUSE
THAT'S NEXT.
WHOLE BUILDER SENTIMENT IS
BEGINNING TO PLUNGE BECAUSE OF
INCREASING INTEREST RATESIMPACTE
CONSTRTION WILL STOP SALE OF
PRE-EXISTING HOMES.
THAT WILL STOP.
HOME VALUE WL PLUMMET TO ENDTHE.
THEN THINGS WILL B
EXPONENTIALLY WSE.
NO SURISE BIDEN IS W
HEMORRHAGING SUPPORTVEN FROM
S OWN BASE.
LOOK AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
26% OF DEMOCRATS WT HIM TO RUN
FOR REELECTION.
ONLY 6% OF AMICANS UNDER 291
DEN TO SERVE SECON TERM.
THEY CAN'T UNDERSTAN HALF O
WHAT HE SAY ANYWAY.
PER USUAL, RECEN CLOSE TO OUR
FUND-RAIR, THERE WAS HIS WIF
THE FIRSTADY DR. JILL BIDEN
FULL OF PAETIC AND LAME
EXCUSETELLING BIG DONOR "THE
ESIDENT HAD SOANY HOPES AND
PLANS AND THINGSE WANTED TO
DO.
EVY TIME HE TURNE AROUND, H
HAD TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS OF
THE MOMENT AND HAD SO MAN
HORRIBLEHINGS THROWN HIS WA"
M NOT SURE WHAT S EXPECTED.
THAT'S WHY IS CALLED BEI
PRESIDENT,HAT'SHY YOU ND
UR FACULTIES ABOUT YOU.
WHAT PAR OF THAT DID YOU NOT
GET GOING INTO THE JOB?
DID YOU NOT THINK THA BIDEN
WOULD FACE UNEXPECTECHALLENGESA?
DID YOU THINK I WOULD BE THAT
EASY?
HE WAS THE VICE PRESIDT IN
EIGHTEARS, IN NAME ONLY, DID
YOU THINA GUY STRUGGLING LIK
YOUR HBAND IS WH A STEEP
GNITIVE PRECIPITOUS DECLINE
COULD PERFORM THE DUTIES OF THE
PRESIDEN?
APPARENTLY SO BECAU NOW
JOE BIDEN IS SO CLEARLYN OVER
HIS HEAD AND EVERYEEK IT GETS
WORSAND WORSE AND WORSE.
THE ART OR NC PUT COMPILATION
OK AT THIS FROM TWO
RSPECTIVES.
ONE AS AN ARICAN CITIZEN, AND
TO THINK AUT ARICAN'S
ENEMIES,OSTILE REGIMES THAT
HA,
SSIAN, IRAN,ENEZUELA,
NORTH KOA.
ASK YOURSELF WHAT DOHEY THINK
WHEN THEY SEE THI
SPEAK OFHE BEST WAY TO GET
SOMETHING DONE IF YOU HO IT
NEARND DEAR TO YOU THATOU'D
LIKE TO BE AE TO -- ANYWAY.
OM CHARLOTTE, ANOTHER LINE
GOING IN FLORIDAOWN TO TAMPA.
THE IDEA THAT --
LOS ANGELES AND -- WHAT AM I
DOING HERE?
FORWO REASONS.
ONE, TO.
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE IN AAY -- WHA DO
I Y ANOTHER WAY.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU FEEL?FORGETT
REPUBLICANS, DOE THAT GUY SEEM
UP TO THE JOB OF BEING
PRESIDENT?
HE OBVIOUSLY IS NOT.
WHAT YOU SAW SADLY IT'S JUST THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
TO DRIVE HOME A POINT LET'S
PLAY A FEW MORE CLIPS JUS TO
REALLY ETCH THIS INTO YOUR MIND.
WHAT DO YOU AMERIN ENEMIES
HOSTILE REGIMES THINK WH THEY
SEE THIS FROM A UNITED ATES
PRESENT?
YOU DECE.
>> THE POLITICAL COVERAGE.♪ ♪
LOOK ...
SOME OF E POLITICAL PLAYERS
AN SOME OF THE...
LET ME ASK YOA RHETORICAL
QUESTION.
NO, I WANT, ANYWAY.
>> Sean: A GUY TT STRUGGLING
SPEAK AND SIMPLE BASIC FACTS
AND NAMES, FOLLOW SIC SIMPLE
INRUCTIONS, SAY HELLO, SIT
DOWN FROM A NOTE CARD IS NOT
CAPABLE OF BEING PREDENT.
A G WHO NEE LONG WEEKENDS TO
RECOVER FROM ONE TRIP, ONE
TRAVELING EERIENCE DOES NOT
HAVE THE STAMINA TO BE
PRIDENT.
BIDEN WAKES UP LAT AND GOES TO
BED ELY SHOULD NOT BE
PRIDENT.
A GUY THAT TURNS AND TRIES TO
SHAK HANDS WITH THIN AIR AGAINAT
PRESIDENT.
ASK WHAT DO I DO NOW?
I CAN' TAKE QUESTIONS OR
THEY'LL GET MAD A ME.
FINALLYLMOST EVERYONE AGRE
WITH WHATE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU
FROM THE BEGINNING.
IF JOEIDEN IS NOT FIT TO B
PRESIDENT.
HE'S NOT FIT TO SERVE.
HE SHOD BE SPENDING HISINAL
YEARS ENJOYING RETIREMEN ON A
BEH IN DELAWARE NOT SCREWING
UP THE COUNT INHE
WHITE USE AND PUTTING THE
ENTIRE WORLDN HARM'S WAY.
UNFORTUNELY FOR DEMOCRATS,HE
OPTION TO REPLACE JOE IN 2024
AREN'T LOOKING GAT EITHER TO
SAY THE LEAST
ACCORDING TO
HE WASHINGTON POST,"HE
NUMBER ONE REPLACEMENT CANDIDATE
IS MAYOR PETE?
E TRANSPORTATION CRETARY?
NOW SPENDING A BLION PACKS TAX R
DOLLARS TO MAKE HIGHWAYS LS
RACIST.
BEHIND HIM VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARSS ONE OF THE MOST
UNPULAR POLITICIANSND THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
CALL H THE GIGGLING
VICE PRESIDENT.
BIDEN'S BORDS ARE ISN'T BUSYSOL.
SHE'S NOT EXACTLY INSPIRI THE
NATION WITH SE OF T WOR
SPEECH EVER GIVEN IN T
HISTORY OF TT OFFICE.
HARR TYPICALLY SOUNDS LIKE
E'S GIVING A BOOKEPORT O A
NOVEL TT SHE NER READ.
IF Y ONLY READ THE CLIFF
NOTES.
LATEST EXAMPLE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'M HERE TO ASK YOU, DO WHAT
YOU KNOW HOW TO DO, BECSE WHEN
U DO WHAT YOU DO, ON ALL THESE
ISSUES, THE ARICAN PEOPLE WIN.
>> Sn: DO WHAT YOU HAV TO
DO WHAT YOU DO.
EVERDUE DAY.
APPARENTLY THE VE PRESIDENT I
WORSE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
THE SPEECHWRIR WHO SERD FOR
UR MONTHS, YOU CAN BLAME THE
VICE PRESIDENT SO I GUESS YOU
FIRE THE SPEHWRITER WCH
BRIN